d'accord
[Musique]
nous pouvons parler aux robots et interagir
avec eux en utilisant le langage naturel
soit via une interface de chat, soit
via une interface parlée
et l'interface parlée rend l'
interaction très naturelle
[Musique]
je vais ouvrir le tiroir
[  Musique] ce que
nous essayons de comprendre, c'est comment
permettre aux robots de manipuler les choses
parce que c'est là que se trouve la véritable utilité
dans un environnement centré sur l'humain, nous
voulons un robot qui vous aide à ranger la pièce ou
qui
vous aide à connaître votre cuisine ou
[Musique]
vous aide à enlever les déchets
nous allons y aller
[Musique]